Happy Avatar day team Avatar is back so they
dropped a brand new avatar the last airbender
Netflix trailer video so we'll break it all down
and explain what's happening with the series also
talk about the animated movies that Mike and
Bryan are making in the new animated episodes
of avatar The Last Airbender that they're going
to be doing there'll be a couple new series that
they're currently working on right now in addition
to new animated movies on top of the live-action
Netflix episodes we're going full Avatar Into
The Avatar verse we'll be getting Avatar series
and movies for like the next hundred years we'll
be like old men and women talking about this to
our great great grandchildren if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the episodes I will do episode videos for the
Netflix series when it premieres in 2024 obviously
they also confirmed that they're holding it till
2024 mostly to work on the special effects for all
the bending abilities one of the interesting
changes though to this new intro is that you
don't see the actual Benders I'm assuming that
they'll change this when they release the next
big trailer let the final version in the intros
for all the actual live-action episodes will be
closer to the animated intro scenes and they
don't use the original theme song in the intro
from the Animated Series during this as well
Jeremy Zuckerman said that he's not doing music
for the series so I'm assuming that the music for
the live-action Avatar series will be a little bit
different from the animated Avatar series but
just like when they got to Legend of Korra he
wrote new music for that they used some of the
music from the original series too like some
music recurs across all Avatar series they don't
say exactly when it's going to Premiere 2024 but
I'm assuming it'll be the first half by the spring
at least talking about the new animated avatar The
Last Airbender movie that they're making with the
gang they just revealed a first look for that at
cinemacon this year it's meant to tee up the big
Avatar universe that they're expanding basically
when they announced they were coming back to
the project to the series they were going to
be making a bunch more TV series set in the
universe and a bunch more movies as well but
all in the Animated Universe all the live action
stuff that's completely separate that's Netflix
stuff the very first movie they're doing is about
the adult gang as you can see here set after the
events of book three the funny thing about this is
it actually doesn't look too different from a lot
of the fan art that we've seen from everybody the
last several years one of the notable differences
though is that Aang does not have a beard and
he does have a beard in all the adult Ang that
we see during Korra during those episodes he was
actually closer to the end of his life closer to
his 40s looking at that epic ponytail the Zuko has
how much older guitar looks I would say they're
within 10 years older than the end of book 3. like
very early 20s Aang even though technically his
body is much much older they didn't say who the
villain's going to be but they're not doing the
exact plot of the comics but they did say that the
plot of the comics will start to become Canon for
the most part it's all meant to be Canon if you
haven't read any of those the comics basically
tell you exactly what happens to them right after
the finale like Aang in fire lord Zuko create
Republic City or they start creating republics
that he takes a while to build it Azula comes
back to harass Zuko doing exactly what you would
expect adult Azula to do they explain who toff's
baby daddies are are she had two different baby
daddies and they explained what happened to Zuko's
mother I've already done a couple videos about
all that stuff so I'll post links for that stuff
in the description below and really the only
thing that you don't get from this first look
scene here is that it's actually going to be 3D
animation they did say that for all the different
upcoming Avatar series and movies they would all
probably have slightly different animation Styles
they have about three different movies that are in
development right now the adult gang one is just
the first one that means that all three of those
movies might have slightly different animation
Styles as well as the TV series in the way that
the original avatar The Last Airbender series had
a very different animation style from Legend
of Korra when that aired Bryan kenyetsko was
recently talking about the future of Avatar
as well too now we're getting to expand the
franchise in different directions all at once
now we're making a movie our first movie so
that always as an artist that that was like really
alluring to me I can't really wrap my head around
the Final Mix and the final color correction on
the feature now we're talking about doing multiple
projects at the same time including feature films
it's really cool to hear him talking about Avatar
again they've been working on it for a while now
they're just really quiet about it they said that
it took them almost four years to develop the
original avatar The Last Airbender series and
they only announced the project close to about
four years ago which is why it's taking so long
for them to release all this because they're
trying to build out an entire universe but
the really good news you probably just saw in
your feeds is that Mike and Bryan's first knew
remember this first new but not last new animated
avatar The Last Airbender series is now confirmed
to be about the next Avatar after akora moving the
timeline forward the same way that Cora just came
after Aang The Avatar cycle goes fire air water
and Earth so when Mike and Bryan first announced
that they were making new animated Avatar movies
and series most of us just speculated that they'd
logically just move the timeline forward and
do the next Avatar after Korra which would be
an earthbender avatar but they are also doing
stuff earlier in the timeline too like they'll
be jumping all over the timeline and a bunch of
different types of projects I'll explain later
in the video but the new Full regular animated
series will just pick up after Cora has died in
the new earthbender Avatar is born they have
it announced who the person's name is or if
it's going to be a female or a male Avatar but
if you've been following the story of Korra in
the comics that explains what happens to her after
the events of the finale her lifespan is meant to
be fairly typical of the majority of all avatars
meaning she lived Beyond 100 years old which you
would consider like a slightly longer life span
for a really healthy person living past 100 in the
Avatar Universe isn't uncommon for regular people
the only major exceptions to how long avatars
live are when they're either killed in battle like
killed under mysterious circumstances or the most
famous examples being Avatar Kyoshi and Avatar
Aang Aang died when he was 66 chronologically
and at the time it was considered a very early
death in terms of his year spent walking around
like chronologically but biologically he died at
the age of 166 because he was stuck in the ice
for over 100 years and being in the Avatar state
for that long just took a huge toll on his body
had that not happened he would have just lived
a normal lifespan well past 100 years the other
exception like on the other end of that is Kyoshi
who lived way longer than most avatars she was
about 200 years old when she died but she was a
beast she was also just physically way bigger than
most people one of the new animated movies that
they're doing is a Kyoshi movie I'll talk about
that later in the video so they are doing a lot of
new Kyoshi stuff too but the idea is that this new
earthbender Avatar series after Cora would pick
up about 100 years after the quora finale close
to or at real world present day like a modern day
Avatar like a lot of people wondered that they
would do so the idea is that during the events of
Korra Republic City for example had a very Roaring
20s inspired Vibe with the design and the level
of Technology the way bending had evolved this
new series would look more like our real world
present day like an avatar walking around with
our current level of Technology but remember this
is the Avatar universe so it's not always like a
one-to-one comparison like the best example being
will this new Avatar be the one who walks around
with an iPhone in his or her pocket like The Tik
Tok Avatar please don't put Tik Tok in the Avatar
Universe we could do without that this is where I
think Mike and Bryan will change a couple things
like the current period in the Avatar universe
will just be similar in the way science starts
to rival traditional use of bending elements like
during the events of Legend of Korra their big
thing was showing that just 50 years plus after
avatar The Last Airbender Society had evolved
to start harnessing lightning bending powers to
generate electricity people like kuvira began to
harness Spirit energy taken from the vines in
the world tree using them to power weapons and
Technology people like bayfong were using their
metal bending abilities to power their technology
for crime fighting like not just their tactics
but also their armor their Weaponry what we'll
probably see is more of that kind of thinking like
scientists in the future of the Avatar Universe
finding new ways of exploiting bending energy
cosmic energy from the spirit world for weapons
for technology even for just regular everyday
stuff that non-benders use and take advantage of
they started to get into this idea during course
season 4 where some people have started to harvest
abuse Spirit energy cosmic energy the spirit world
started to fight back the spirits themselves the
biological life that originated there like the
vines that started to take over Republic City
so in the way the chorus Series in general had
started to get into the balance between bending
and Technology a modern-day Avatar series would
be all about that like the other cool thing being
that every time they do Advance the timeline the
Avatar universe is that bending in general just
evolves as people come up with more creative ways
to use their bending Powers you start to see even
more specialized forms of sub-bending let me know
in the comments what kind of sub styles of bending
do you want to see just based on what we've
already seen from sub bending Styles right now the
target release date is the end of 2025 right after
the new animated avatar The Last Airbender movie
comes out so you kind of see what they're doing
here they're going to try and release that new
movie in October 2025 and then like right after
that the series picks up the new Avatar series
will run at the same time as the live-action
Netflix series but the live-action Netflix
episodes are just retelling the events of the
original avatar The Last Airbender animated series
with Aang and by the time the new animated series
premieres will be in like season 2 of the live
action series and while that's happening every
two or every three years they'll release a new
animated Avatar movie they've already announced
three movies total the first one is with the adult
gang but the second two are a zuko movie and a
Kyoshi movie they didn't say which order they're
going to do them in but I'm assuming right now it
starts with the Avatar The Last Airbender movie
about the whole gang because they've confirmed
that then the Zuko movie and then the Kyoshi
movie there will be more animated movies and more
animated series after these first ones from Mike
and Bryan they probably won't talk about the other
stuff till after later seasons of this first new
one though Netflix just released their one-piece
trailer for The live-action one piece series I'll
do a video for that as soon as possible too so be
sure to enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss that click here for all my other videos
about the upcoming avatar The Last Airbender
new series in movies and click here for that one
piece trailer I'll update the link as soon as I
post it thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!